Have you ever felt like your faith is threatened when you walk into a science
classroom? Maybe you've felt like science and faith are at odds.
Or maybe you've even heard the narrative that science and faith are at war.
Should we feel like our religious beliefs are threatened when we walk into a science
classroom? Well, it's easy to think that we ought to check our religious beliefs at
the door when we come into the arena of science.
But as tempting as this may be, this is not an option for a thoughtful Christian.
You might be pleasantly surprised to discover that it's actually the Christian
worldview that is largely responsible for the birth of science.
You see, there are certain ideas within the Judeo-Christian tradition that gave both
the motivation and the intellectual backing for the birth of modern science.
Many scientific pioneers, if not most scientific pioneers, were motivated
to do science because of their theistic, and in particular, Christian, belief
system. Scientific pioneers like Copernicus, Boyle, Galileo, Kepler,
Newton, and many, many more did science because of their Christian worldview.
Francis Bacon believed God meant for us to explore the many mysteries that filled
the natural world. Kepler wrote, The chief aim of all investigations of the external
world, should be to discover the rational order which has been imposed on it by God,
in which he revealed to us in the language of mathematics.
Newton believed his scientific discoveries offered convincing evidence for the
existence and creativity of God.
This most beautiful system of sun, planets, and comets, could only proceed from the
counsel and dominion of an intelligent and powerful being.
There are three main reasons why, the scientific revolution, took place in a culture
shaped by a theistic worldview the first reason is that Christianity in particular
teaches that God is orderly he's rational in his very being and the universe is
orderly and since we're made in God's image we are capable of understanding the
world in which we live the world is not chaotic it's orderly second Christianity
sanctioned science in other words science was done to care for and
alleviate the suffering of human beings and to protect and care for creation and
third Christianity gave the motivation is that science was to be done to bring glory
to God despite the common narrative that we hear that science is at odds
with faith it's actually the Christian worldview that contributed enormously to the
rise of science
naturalism actually undermines science Charles Darwin once said but then
with me the horrid doubt always arises whether the conviction of man's mind which
has been developed from the mind of lower animals are of any value or at all
trustworthy would anyone trust in the convictions of a monkey's mind if there are
any convictions in such a mind
in other words what Darwin is saying is that his very naturalistic evolutionary
theory undermines any basis we have for concluding that evolution is true
now here's why according to his naturalistic theory the brain is the result of this
blind purposeless material process it's a large accident so
this raises a troubling question how do you know we can trust anything that the
brain tells us is true now this isn't a problem for the Christian worldview because
God is reasonable the world is orderly and we've been made in God's image to
understand the world in which we're placed you see
naturalists can do science but they have to borrow from the Judeo-Christian
worldview to do so science and faith are not at odds
now there certainly are distinct scientific and distinct theological questions for
example in science the question of how many oxygen atoms are in a water molecule or
in theology what is the nature of an angel those are distinct questions that belong
in their own discipline but there are times when science and theology overlap
questions such as the origin of the universe the origin of mankind and the
historical resurrection sometimes science and faith intersect
the idea that Christianity is at war with science is mistaken it's a misreading
of the historical scientific theological and philosophical evidence
you see Christians have always taught that God speaks through two books the book of
nature and the book of scripture the book of nature means that God has made himself
known in creation creation speaks truths about the Creator but God
also has made himself known through the scriptures God's Word reveals truth about
his character and also his design for mankind now we can certainly
misinterpret the scriptures and we can misunderstand the scientific evidence but
when done accurately both books reveal truths about the Creator